er schloss damit wir noch über robert
hörberg sprechen können so bewege aber
vielleicht möchten sie auch in diesem
zusammenhang warum man herbergs politik
sprechen das heißt das mache ich das
meinen natürlich soll das festgeschehen
lieblingspulli haben das werde ich
wir haben ja tatsächlich neben corona
und auch andere wichtige themen und
diese woche ist eine bombe geplatzt oder
es kam völlig überraschend die nachricht
dass robert habeck in zukunft ein
förderprogramm einstellt dass
klimafreundliches bauen ermöglichen soll
und da gibt es keine lange frist von
einigen wochen oder monaten sondern das
hat er sofort gemacht viele häuslebauer
viele menschen in deutschland die genau
mit diesem förderprogramm ihren hausbau
kalkuliert hatten die gucken jetzt in
die röhre die können ihren hausbau
teilweise nicht mehr finanzieren und
auch in zukunft werden vielen familien
gelder fehlen gelder um ihre häuser
klimafreundlich zu bauen und das ist
wirklich ein schlag ins gesicht für alle
diejenigen die
attraktives die günstiges die
klimafreundliches bauen sich in
deutschland wünschen dass ausgerechnet
ein grüner minister als im prinzip als
erste amtshandlung die förderprogramme
für klimafreundliches bauen streicht das
geht gar nicht deswegen meine forderung
robert habeck bitte stoppen sie diese
politische entscheidung machen sie ihren
fehler rückgängig wir brauchen auch in
zukunft förderprogramme für
klimafreundliches bauen in deutschland
also was ihr wirklich frechheit ist ist
es auch ohne lange fristen zu machen
denn jeder der schon mal irgendwie geld
in der immobilie investiert hat weiß ja
dass man anlauf braucht wenn man bauen
will braucht man erst recht anlauf dann
muss man planungssicherheit haben
planungssicherheit hat im kern vertrauen
auf das was geld und wenn sich dann
schnell was ändert ist es furchtbar ich
finde auch noch was anderes furchtbar
wir beklagen doch alle immer das in
deutschland zur altersvorsorge die
eigenen vier wände die in anderen
ländern eine viel größere rolle bei
menschen spielen sie sagen wir haben
unsere eigenen vier wände werden
wohnungen wir haben ein kleines haus da
ganz viel drin diese möglichkeit wird
jetzt ja erst mal wenn ich für unmöglich
so doch erschwert und das führt glaube
ich zu dingen die in eine ganz ganz
falsche richtung gehen und drückt auch
dem robert habeck den ich irgendwie aus
einer anderen perspektive
für muntere hätte ich fast gesagt aber
er respektiere nämlich dass er wirklich
sein weg geht und auch wirklich
glaubhaft versichert er will eine
veränderte art wie wir sozusagen mit dem
thema umwelt umgehen da würde ich sagen
da bin ich nicht immer seiner meinung
aber das imponiert mir wir sozusagen
vorangeht da liegt er voll daneben
ausrufezeichen hinter die grünen die
haben sich ja im leben auch schon immer
sehr imponiert mir immer imponiert wie
ist deine haltung ich bin ja nicht grün
das habe ich ja schon mal öffentlich
gemacht kann ich jetzt gern wieder sagen
ich frage mich auch ein bisschen ich bin
etwas wundert klaus was die jetzt so
stark imponiert nehmen wir zum beispiel
windrad
windkrafträder die wollen die grünen uns
ja am liebsten direkt vors haus bauen
und die entwertung des eigentlich ist es
wirklich also was die grünen vorhaben
ist eine ökodiktatur für mich nach wie
vor und ich verabscheue die
sozialistischen ansätze das sind nicht
sehr froh dass das thema heute abend
herrschen andere ist also da habe ich
jetzt ehrlich gesagt in der ampel
regierung noch nicht so viel sozialismus
richtig erweisen nicht durchgesetzt
dabei die fdp ist ja auch dabei noch mal
ein unding spd ist aktuell moderate ich
will nochmal einmal meine gedanken uns
sozusagen zu sortieren was mir imponiert
ja also ich finde die geschwindigkeit
mit der die grünen dinge umsetzen wollen
falsch weil sie die menschen nicht
mitnehmen aber ich finde manches von dem
was sie anstreben richtig und mir
imponiert dass sie tatsächlich ein
anderes zusammenleben ein
zukunftsorientiertes zusammenleben
zumindest für mich glaubhaft anstreben
und dass sie auch die schrittfolge
sozusagen angehen weil di resta tagen
startet das ist das was ich der früheren
regierung vorwerfen dass sie gerade in
denen fragen klima etc nicht
vorangekommen ich glaube das wird ein
ganz ganz wichtiges thema sein in der
zukunft noch aber gegen ende der sendung
möchte ich noch einmal sahra wagenknecht
mit reinnehmen vorwagen echt wir haben
jetzt eine stunde diskutiert geht es
ihnen schlechter schon oder cola
schön also zum glück hat sich da nichts
verschlechtert wobei auch wirklich ganz
gut finde dass wir jetzt nicht nur über
gruner reden ich würde mir auch dass
also wirklich wünschen auch deshalb
wünsche ich mir dass diese pandemie zu
ende geht wir haben so viele auch andere
wichtige gesellschaftliche fragen über
die eigentlich kaum noch geredet wird
also das soziale fragen sind ob das eben
auch die frage von umwelt ist oder auch
die frage ob das was die grünen unter
grüner politik verstehen überhaupt
irgendwie der umwelt nützt und dem klima
das sind ja alles ganz wichtige fragen
die sind alle hierzu unter ferner liefen
und am rand und ich hoffe einfach dass
wir bald wieder auch die den kopf dafür
frei haben und auch nicht jeden abend
sozusagen die abendnachrichten und alles
was an nachrücken einem so überflutet
nur mit corona gefahr wir vorweg nicht
wenn wie lange dauert das jetzt bis sie
wieder raus dürfen aus der quarantäne
und freuen sie sich darüber dass sie
dann diesen genesenen status haben wo
sie über rein dürfen na ja das hängt
also wann ich wieder rauskommen das
hängt davon ab wie ist verkürzt worden
ob ich mich frei tester also sprich ob
ich dann eben negative testergebnisse
habe der genesenen status denen habe ich
das habe ich jetzt auch erst gelernt
tatsächlich aus 28 tage nach meinem
positiven test also in einem monat und
dann auch nur für mein mörder also noch
nicht mal drei sind das ja